if you're talking about um cognitive
performance this could actually be very
beneficial the early part of the day is
interesting because the one thing that's
not often discussed is the transition
out of sleep so there's a book
um i think it's called winston
churchill's nap and it's about naps and
and the transition between wake and
sleep as a valuable period a long time
ago
someone who i respect a lot was
mentoring me said um be very careful
about bringing in someone else's sensory
experience early in the day some people
have taken this to the extreme when i
was a graduate student at berkeley there
was a guy
there as a professor
brilliant odd but brilliant
who was so fixated on this concept that
he wouldn't look at faces in the early
part of the day
because he just didn't want to anything
else to impact him so when i wake up i'm
very drowsy i sleep well but i i don't
emerge from that very quickly i need a
lot of caffeine to wake up and
whatnot but there's this concept of
getting the download from sleep
which is you know in sleep you're you
were essentially expunging the things
that you don't need the stuff that was
meaningless from the previous day but
you were also running variations on
these algorithms of whatever it is
you're trying to work out in life on
short time scales like the previous day
and long time scales like your whole
life it's a brain state that would be
useless in waking you wouldn't get
anything done you'd be the person
talking yourself in the hallway or
something about something that no one
else can see but in those states the
theory is that you arrive at certain
solutions and those solutions will
reveal themselves in the early part of
the day unless you interfere with them
by bringing in social media is a good
example of you immediately enter
somebody else's
space-time sensory relationship someone
is the conductor of your thoughts in
that case allowing the download to occur
in the early part of the day
and asking the question
am i more in my head or extern am i in
more of an enteroceptive or
exteroceptive mode and depending on the
kind of work you need to do if it's it
sounds like for you it's very
enteroceptive in the and very you've got
a lot of thinking going on a lot of
computing going on allowing yourself to
transition out of that sleep state and
arrive with those solutions from sleep
and plug into the work really deeply and
only then allowing things like music
news social media there is a sweet spot
if you will
where
the level of internal autonomic arousal
aka stress or alertness whatever you
want to call it
is
ideally matched to
the speed of whatever challenge you have
got to be facing in the outside world so
we all have um perception of the outside
world as exteroception and the
perception of our internal real estate
interoception when interoception and
exterior reception are matched along a
couple dimensions performance uh tends
to increase tends to be in optimal range
so let's say you're trying to learn
something new on the guitar i'm not
saying that being in these super high
states of activation are the best place
for you to be in order to learn
it may be
that you your internal
arousal needs to be at a level where
your analysis of space and time has to
be well matched to the information
coming in and what you're trying to do
in terms of performance in terms of
playing chords and notes and so forth
with the guitar learning for instance it
might actually be that you want to be
almost sleepy
almost in a uh kind of drowsy state to
be able to and i don't play with music
so i can't i'm guessing here but send
some of the nuance and the chords or the
ways that you're to be relaxed enough
that your fingers can follow an external
cue so matching the movement of your
fingers to something that's pure
exteroception
now in these cases of high threat where
things are coming in quickly and animals
and humans need to react very quickly
the higher your state of autonomic
arousal the better because you're
slicing time more finely just because of
the way the autonomic system works it
and so there is no perfect autonomic
state for performance but i do believe
that optimal or peak performance is
going to arise when internal state is
ideally matched to base-time features of
the external demands
[Music]